and first on CBS this morning the
daughters of an American man held in
Syria for nearly two years are both
going public asking President Trump to
help bring their father home
Maj Kamal Maas was detained in Syria's
capital in 2017 now since then his
daughter's hula and Miriam have been
working quietly with the State
Department to find their father Janet
shamlian spoke with the two women in
Grand Prairie Texas just outside Dallas
we're pretty confident he is still alive
and I feel that he is still alive
in my heart Mirian comella and her
sister eulah pray every day for their
father's safe return I think we
discussed him on a daily basis Maj camel
Maas a 61 year old therapist and
grandfather was last seen in war-torn
Syria while crossing a government check
point where he was detained can you
think of any reason why he might have
been stopped and held anything no I mean
he went into his used passport and he
knew that he was going into relatives I
mean that's what we know but a Mama's
family has been largely silent about
their father's disappearance
fearing attention to his case would put
him in danger but after two years
without any leads the family is now
making a public appeal to President
Trump
president Trump's success rate at
returning detained prisoners we've high
faith that he's going to be able to do
the same thing with our father foreign
policy expert Paul Salim well the Syrian
government like I suppose many
adversarial governments to the u.s. want
leverage against the u.s. want ways to
put pressure on the u.s. the Syrian
regime probably detained him in order to
get Washington's attention and perhaps
to negotiate towards normalizing
relations with Syria a Oma's emigrated
to the US when he was six and became a
dual citizen American every way possible
don't let this fool you I mean my father
always taught us that this is your
country this you're not going anywhere
we were all born here and raised here a
therapist who's offered free counseling
to victims of Hurricane Katrina and the
Indonesian tsunami
now Mama's travelled the world his
family wants him here what would you say
your dad right now if he could hear you
dad
we love you we miss you working hard to
wind you home I was Janet shamlian who
filed that report the common laws family
sent the president a letter in October
pleading for his help in getting Maj
Kamala's out of Syria the family says
the White House has received a letter
but the president has not yet responded
you can really feel their pain we hope
somebody at the White House is listening
we'll help them out